In the video about dehydration
we saw that we could start with a glucose molecule
and by dehydration
it can be linked to another glucose molecule.
In this way we get the disaccharide maltose,
consisting of two molecules of glucose.
If we continue to add,
we can form longer chains of glucose molecules.
In the process where we associate monosaccharides,
glucose is the most common example,
& lt; / RTI & gt;
polysaccharides.
Polysaccharides. It's a polysaccharide.
There are many different and interesting examples
for polysaccharides around us.
Most notably polysaccharides of glucose,
based on glucose.
Here is a bowl of mashed potatoes,
which consists mainly of starch.
A starch consists of glucose.
This is starchy here.
The shell of many insects and animals such as lobsters,
and the wings of these insects
is made from chitin.
The chitin is also a polysaccharide.
It is made of glucose modification chains.
This is chitin here.
Strongly like starch, it's glycogen in our muscles.
It stores energy in the muscles.
There is also cellulose,
which is probably anywhere around you.
Cellulose builds things like -
as they are all around you,
you may not be aware.
But cellulose is in the composition of
paper and wood.
It builds the cell walls of the plants.
Here's a picture of cotton
in its natural form.
Cotton is actually one of the purest forms of cellulose,
it is composed of 90% cellulose.
If we increase a cotton thread,
or a single strand of cellulose
we will see glucose molecules.
You see this here is a glucose molecule.
Then you see another molecule of glucose.
This circuit has formed
in dehydration.
And the difference between starch and cellulose,
the main difference is how
the connections between their monomers have formed.
In starch, the molecules glucose
connect, as we saw in the video on dehydration.
While in cellulose, they turn.
We see that oxygen here points in this direction,
oxygen points in that direction,
oxygen points in that direction.
You can search for more information about cellulose.
Interestingly, its structure is due
of the hydrogen bonds that are formed
between the partially negative,
strongly electronegative oxygen atoms in the chain
and the partially positive hydrogen atoms of another chain.
These bonds give the structure of the cellulose.
Polysaccharides are many, very interesting things.
The question is -
how are they degraded?
If we eat this potato puree,
how we will turn it into glucose,
to extract energy from it?
This is done by hydrolysis.
We can divide the word into parts.
If we have the prefix "hydro"
this suggests that it is something related to water.
Then, if we see "lysis," then we're breaking down something.
Something is broken down.
It means something is broken down by water.
This is exactly what happens during hydrolysis.
We have this polysaccharide,
to pour in and the water molecule in it,
the water molecule will be able to
to break down one of these links.
We can get something like -
This circuit can continue in both directions,
but we will get something like this.
Something that looks like this.
This half of the water molecule is separated,
to break this link.
Hydrolysis is the opposite of dehydration.
Let's see if we can
to understand what is happening.
This is maltose here.
It is disaccharide, it consists of only two, connected
glucose molecules.
If we add
another molecule of glucose here
and one more here,
we will have starch work.
Or with glycogen.
If this was turned,
and all were turned,
we would talk about pulp.
But let us think about the mechanism,
by which the connection is destroyed.
It's just hydrolysis upside down.
It will be like a revision.
The oxygen atom here is two free electronic pairs.
There is always a chance if you hit something,
immediately bind to a hydrogen proton,
who just stays in the solution.
Suppose this happens
in aqueous solution. It happens in water.
You can just catch a hydrogen proton
of a passing hydroxone ion.
If this happens, a covalent bond will be formed
and will get a positive charge.
And about these two carbon atoms -
But let's focus on the carbon atom here.
This will be the so-called organic chemistry,
good leaving group.
These electrons,
oxygen may want to take them back,
because it has a positive charge.
Oxygen is highly electronegative
and the atoms can meet in the right way.
If they interact in the right way,
we may have another water molecule.
Here too, the additional molecule of water is very important
for our hydrology.
Let's say this is another water molecule,
just passing at the right moment.
It can be connected to this carbon atom
right here.
By forming a bond with the carbon atom,
he says, "Okay, they'll share with me"
"a little more electrons, let me release these electrons."
He releases these electrons.
What is left?
Move here.
I will use different colors.
This relationship, which has just been created,
is this link here.
This oxygen atom is here.
He actually has another hydrogen atom attached to it,
I will mark it.
When joining
will have a positive charge.
Then this bond here returns to this oxygen atom.
This oxygen here
is here.
When it all began, this atom -
This hydrogen proton, which I grabbed and stained in orange
is this one.
This is here.
This atom has taken a hydrogen proton
and now this can yield
hydrogen proton in the solution.
If a molecule of water passes, it can
to connect this hydrogen proton and become a hydroxone ion.
So he took a water proton and returns it,
it gets -
Uses this water molecule here,
to break the connection.
That's why it has a positive charge.
It may be, passing a hydroxone ion,
who will just betray him.
Here, we have
two distinct glucose molecules.
We have broken the relationship.
If these were parts of a chain, then we've broken down the chain.
If we deal with maltose,
we degraded it on
its constituent molecules of glucose.
The example here is with glucose
or maltose,
but it could have been sucrose,
in this case, we would have degraded sucrose by hydrolysis
a glucose molecule and a fructose molecule.
This is a very important reaction in biology.